that you see wage deflation and
productivity in Britain going down every
single year in fact the productivity
drop has been alarming over the course
of the last 10 years and what that
suggests is we've become the cheap labor
economy of the European time zone and
that actually this is no net benefit
overall to the UK economy at all though
I confess it's good for the big
employers it's good for the big
landowners is it good for Audrey Britons
and taxpayers and workers no well on the
productivity point is fair to say that
you know across the western world
productivity has been down since the
recession partly because companies have
kept people employed well that's
certainly true but Britain's
productivity drop is really very
alarming very very alarming as his wage
compression and yet it's funny because
five or ten years ago I was on programs
like this saying that get a mass
increase in unskilled and semi-skilled
migration would drive down wages I was
told what a dreadful person I was how
dare I scapegoat migrants which I was
never trying to do now Mark Carney the
governor of the Bank of England says the
same thing so there are more people
being employed but a more migrant labour
people coming into Britain and finding
work of some kind is this actually
helping Britain I'm not sure the answer
is yes what do you think of the measures
announced by the Prime Minister
particularly clamping down on illegal
working are they going to have any
effect you think none you know it's very
interesting I drove through cali this
morning I've never seen so many people
attended to breaking the lorries you
know I even locked my car I was so
concerned by what was going on there the
truth of it is that most people who come
to Britain illegally are paid in cash
they're not paid through the payroll
they haven't got National Insurance
numbers so actually nothing like nothing
the priority said they won't escape the
money all that money would could well
how you confiscate cash without breaking
down people's doors and becoming a sort
of you know totalitarian state is beyond
me that what he's doing he's putting up
a smoke screen to cover the net
migration figures have you seen today
that are now within a couple of thousand
of its absolute peak during the Blair
years when when they literally open the
door to the whole of the world the fact
is under Cameron
controlling immigration has been a
complete than abject failure while the
government's also proposing is limiting
skilled workers coming in from outside
the EU which could affect things like
nurses for the National Health Service
yeah as I understand you kids quite
system you'd actually be letting those
people here of course absolutely we
don't want a system that says no to the
engineer from India of a doctor from
museum or the nurse in faith or the
nurse or whatever it may be in favor of
the unskilled migrant coming from
Romania and Bulgaria I don't know yeah
people scream and shout when I dare talk
about you know nationalities like this
what I'm saying is we now presume in
favor of the European Union against the
rest of the world including the
Commonwealth with whom we have our own
special relationship and what we're
saying is can you have an Australian
star point system not only would it give
a skilled migration and migration that
we need it would actually be more
ethical as well but the reality is that
across the world we're seeing big
migrations people coming in from South
America and the United States and Canada
what's going on in Thailand and
Indonesia at the moment and in truth you
can't stop it can you bring a bit bit
because when you're talking about
hundreds of thousands of people you
really would have to have a police state
to check people out or we have a unique
primary position here we're in Ireland
we are an island there are fewer than
100 potential entry points into this
country as an island we above all the
other countries in the Western world
have more ability to control our borders
we have surrendered that as members of
the European Union and I think actually
Cameron's nightmare today is this these
figures are so bad and particular from
Romania and Bulgaria and countries like
that these figures are so bad there is
no way that a referendum campaign will
not be dominated by the issue of can we
control our own borders or not I was
going to ask you about that because as
you know there are those including some
of your own party who think that you
talking about immigration he's actually
going to
the case against the Britons continued
membership as the European they
generally tend to be people who went to
oxbridge live in westminster are wealthy
and do not meet ordinary working decent
british people and the fact is that
actually the effects of open door
migration on lifestyles communities
cohesion of society have been massive
over the course of the last 15 years and
i think should be and it look I'm up for
a moment saying we shouldn't in the
referendum talk about trade and freeing
ourselves from the EU getting back our
democracy all of those things but
actually having the ability to have an
Australian star point system or not I
think will be the primary issue in this
referendum now